hello everyone
welcome to rational science
first i want to apologize the other day
i had a tremendous pain
lower part of my neck
a headache i had for like
three times in the last year
and it runs all the way to the top of my
head
and uh very painful lasts about eight
hours
terrible stuff anyways uh please let me
know if you can't hear me or
or see me i've had problems lately with
uh youtube but
seems like i've recovered whatever
whatever i did did it right okay
anyways uh
i'm talking about uh extinction
we seem to be approaching extinction
this year we got a war on our hands
right we got a war that's coming up very
likely in ukraine
a hot topic lately
there's another one possibly brewing
in the east in taiwan
maybe another one in iran i mean we seem
to have all these wars all over the
place okay
yeah let me know if uh if you can hear
me just fine okay
i'd really appreciate that
anyways uh
talking about
ukraine
uh
okay thank you
okay thanks uh
uh
talking about ukraine
i have some inside scoop that you
haven't heard about okay
and
it's got to do with you know the uh
american delegation met with a russian
delegation
and they talked
and a lot of that stuff you know was
quiet we didn't know really what
happened behind closed doors
okay so the news did not print out
anything or everything
i got the inside school i've got some
special contacts and i can tell you this
is what happened inside closed doors
okay let me set it up for you give me a
second here
okay
here it goes okay listen tight
hey i think these fellas are phonies
what's that you say you heard me
ordering all about inspiration
you hear what they say they say they've
never been so insulted in their life and
they absolutely refuse to stay here no
no please he didn't mean it tell them he
didn't mean it oh yes we find us now we
didn't even do this
of course you know this means war
that's exactly what happened
okay so that's how it went uh
russians got offended they left the
table and they say they're gonna go to
war
so i think we're in for a nice little
war there okay and
you know if you do a little bit bit of
research you'll probably find some of
the things that i found okay out there
and here it is uh says uh one article
says headed to disaster us russia
hardened stance in talks
okay each one of the mafias right
uh
i don't know if they all want war
okay but
i think some of the military do i mean
they're tired of just sitting around
doing nothing in peace time right that's
a military guy supposed to go to war
that's what he trains for if you have no
war you know what's the point of having
him you know and so i think a lot of
these guys want to have war
and i'm sure the americans want to have
war okay
uh
and i think
not because they can win a war in
ukraine okay i don't think it's got much
to do with that and uh see if you look
at uh
the forces the way they're spread out
okay you can see that uh the russians
are covering
you know ukraine all around okay so they
have a good strategic position
uh not only on land but on
in the sea
and one of the first things that they
might do assuming there's a war is uh
try to create a corridor that goes from
the
crimean peninsula all the way to uh the
russian federation at the east there
okay so that they can
flow material through that space okay
but if you look at ukraine and uh
it gives you let me remove this for a
second here
if you look at ukraine it's um
one of the
last uh
so-called soviet socialist republics
that uh wants to leave the the union you
know uh we used to joke about it where
we said that the they are the union of
fewer and fewer socialist republics
because you know
each one kept leaving and i think russia
of today has is very much in the same
boat you know you have all these uh
countries that used to belong to the
soviet union
and they all speak russian a lot of them
speak russian and
even so they they want to work with the
west okay and so here you see how what's
happened over the last few years you
know you had the warsaw pact included
all that all the colored region
including ukraine
and now although that orange
region
has moved closer to the west quite
closer to the west and what's remaining
are a couple countries there moldova
which is trying to get there
belarus which right now uh is is uh very
friendly with the soviet with the
russians but may uh change government
sometime in the future ukraine has
already changed its government and the
eastern part essentially belongs to
russia you have people who are rooting
for the russian side over there
and so you know i doubt very much
there's going to be a war a full blown
war or that the united states
is interested in winning a war uh in
ukraine i don't think they would be able
to win it militarity i don't think
that's the goal i think the goal here
has more to do with getting western
europe more on the bandwagon with the
american empire i think it's got to do
with that so they they are hoping that
the uh uffsr the you know union of fewer
socialist republics do in fact attack
ukraine
and right now the russians are a little
hesitant because they don't want to
upset uh powers like germany and france
especially you know they want to
chase those away especially into the
hands of the american full-fledged into
the hands of the americans and so what
what is an issue as far as i'm concerned
is this you know these are the uh
pipelines that russia
uh has uh you know feeding gas primarily
into europe
and they're about to release that
northern one the north dream ii nor
north stream two
and
that's probably gonna take a little time
to be approved maybe all the way to june
of this year
and a lot of that's going to be
contingent on what happens with ukraine
so the russians don't want to the
russians don't want to screw that up on
the one hand but on the other hand you
know if the west keeps positioning you
know its pawns and rooks and knights
into ukraine territory or closer and
closer to the russian frontier
uh you know russian can't just sit by
and let that happen
so that's the situation right now on the
one hand you have the west which is
pushing eastward and the russians who
are trying to contain them and contain
also their
ex-socialist republics from joining the
west and ukraine's a big prize in the
sense that it's a big country it's the
ninth country biggest country in the
world
it's just behind argentina
almost the same size almost the same
population 40 plus million
and um
yeah you know and so you know these uh
folks uh uh
maybe a lot of them want to belong to
the west or think that it's more
profitable for them to be
uh with the west and the problem here is
that a lot of that gas the energy with
which to power europe comes from the
east from russia
and so you know it's it's a double-edged
source for everybody you know uh you
can't just go in there and again you can
see the map there you know how uh how
it's divided right now and if ukraine
happens to join the west well it's a big
chunk of land uh lots of population that
suddenly leaves the uh russian uh sphere
of implants
and so this is i think what it's about
uh especially with the uh gas and all
that stuff that's flowing so it's a very
tricky situation and i think the uh it's
one side trying to get the other side to
make them first air
like saying you know uh we want you to
make the first air you we want you to
attack for example ukraine
and the russians know that they can't
just
openly and overtly attack ukraine
because it creates a problem for them so
what do you do well you may have
skirmishes that are not enough to block
um
you know aid for example economic aid or
to
cancel the uh this
gas pipeline
uh because it's not uh
violent enough
full-fledged war would obviously do that
but if it's just a little skirmish here
and there everybody just you know
putting their pawns on the chessboard
well you know is for an interesting war
what i think it's not going to lead to
is a world war in other words a nuclear
war that's what i mean okay uh it's not
going to lead to a nuclear war uh i
think
whatever happens it's going to remain as
a conventional war
and
perhaps it's going to be located
so nobody gives the other side pretext
to go beyond
what they should be doing and turn it
into a major conflict duration okay so
my five cents worth on it
by the way my
mother was
born in
was polish but she was born in territory
that belonged to
that today belongs to ukraine right at
the northeastern
uh north western corner of ukraine
southeastern corner of
poland and she was born little town
there just where the two forces met the
germans and the russians
and uh
if you
look up you can find uh you know again
here you have the pipeline how it's
going through there okay
and
you can see all those
pipes going in there my mother was born
on the
upper left upper left-hand corner there
of ukraine so she was uh today she'd be
i guess considered ukrainian even though
she traveled with uh
polish passport because you know this
was before the
molotov ribbon-trop pack
where they decided to split poland up
then part of that ended up in the soviet
union part of that
poland and territory and some of that
region was eventually given to ukraine
okay
and when ukraine became a separate
country 1989
well uh
we have a situation where you have this
country there right being split up one
more time probably because of war
and my mother was born
on the upper left-hand corner there the
north west part of ukraine
they spoke russian at home
we learned russian when we were kids
a little bit
so i still remember a lot of it but it's
been a long time anyways uh there's uh
something else going on you know with
with this uh
uh war this this situation that you
gotta keep in mind it's got to do with
this question or comment the person made
well it looks more like more and more
like china will take taiwan which will
contribute to china taking the baton in
the economic race although your boss
your old boss intel
is building a factory in arizona and
there's another chip factory being built
in texas that will probably not be
finished before china takes taiwan
uh
well yeah you gotta think about the fact
that there's uh like i said you know the
big prize in taiwan i think is taiwan
semiconductor it would give china
uh
you know would catch up like six years
or so
in chip development with respect to the
west and aside from the fact that you
know right now there's a dearth of chips
around the world and
taiwan semiconductor is if not the
number one it's one of the top uh
providers of chips manufacturers of
chips they have the foundry and
if the chinese
in uh
in beijing
get a hold of that uh you know faucet
they can turn that faucet on and off
anytime they want in fact they can feed
themselves more chips than they feed the
west they can do a lot of stuff there so
i think that's a big prize i'm sure
taiwan has other resources as well but i
think that's one of the big ones okay
that china's after and i'm sure the
united states is very much aware of that
the united states government they
wouldn't want taiwan's semiconductor to
fall into the hands of china
so but you know if you have a war on one
front can you handle wars on two fronts
maybe on three fronts if you have
another one against iran now the united
states empire is pretty big you know
it's got a lot of forces everywhere uh
it also counts with the british and some
other uh strong
you know uh
military
so you know it's uh if if a world war
develops this year with all these
regions going into war china making the
most of the fact that you know the
united states is distracted in in europe
you know they might decide to go for
taiwan so we don't know this is going to
be an interesting year
as far as war is concerned now a lot of
people say bill it's uh
it may be a good idea we have a war it
would really stimulate
the world
economy
well i i tend to disagree with that i
say that
uh you know we're past the uh
manufacturing stage world war one world
war ii were manufacturing wars you know
it did stimulate manufacturing a lot of
car companies uh started making not only
you know cars but uh weapons for for
especially vehicles right for the war
effort and a lot of women came out of
their houses they were housewives and as
their men went off to war they went into
the factories and started building you
know the bullets the guns the cannons uh
tanks for the war effort
that's done with we're never going back
to that again
okay all the uh equipment is now already
in the hands of people everybody's armed
to their teeth out there and if they
need more weapons which they very likely
will uh you know they're already set up
to to do that kind of work they they
know that uh if they need to create more
weapons
uh they can get them you know rolling
anytime they want because everything is
set up everybody's been preparing for
such a war but
it's not like billions of people are
going to go into the factories and start
working
that's not going to happen people are
going to stay you know in their offices
doing
programming and playing games
and very few people will really be
absorbed into the manufacturing era
area
and never again will we go back to
manufacturing okay the age of
manufacturing is over so a war will not
stimulate the economy at least from a
manufacturing standpoint and people
should forget about manufacturing
inventions technology
it's dead it'll never happen again
you missed it you know
it happened to your grandparents not to
you okay
so yeah
uh i don't think uh war this time around
will stimulate the global economy okay
now there are obviously recess uh you
know
internet resources involved right uh in
in the next war right if there is such a
world war but you know uh
the weapons we have today like you know
i was mentioning a couple weeks ago that
uh the russians tested a killer
satellite
you know satellite that goes out there
and kills satellite communication
satellites
you know if they start playing around
with all that up there in space we're
all dead we're all dead we don't need to
send the send the the nukes first of all
we wouldn't have a way to guide them
without the satellites but aside from
that you know all the money would be
gone in the world
so if they happen to kill all the
satellites we're all dead
and uh that's how fragile our lives are
really in the hands of a few who take
those decisions
uh so you know again uh this is not
gonna be first of all a long-lasting war
if it's in a big war if it's a small war
it can last years and this could just be
the starting point what's happening now
but if it's a long war like you know a
world
i mean a big war like a world war
forget it it's going to be done in in a
matter of weeks
and we have the power today we have the
energy okay
okay uh talking about uh that region
there's another
country that's involved in in some kind
of problems and it's kazakhstan they had
to intervene in there with troops to
quiet the uh population so to speak
and fell says disrupting mining kazakhs
damn i put right because
i think uh all this uh crypto coin is
more or less a scam you know even though
i i'm on record uh i buy crypto coins as
well i play the market as well play the
casino the one arm bandits as well okay
i want you to know that but uh yeah it's
a scam it's uh it's just
this not real okay it's just for people
who want to play the game like going to
vegas no different
[Music]
says money in kazakhstan uh would
doesn't really have an effect on prices
on on the price the production of
bitcoin stays the same someone else will
simply mined it mine it the only thing
it would have an effect on is sending
fees
yeah the only thing that i'm saying here
is that you know 20 of the mark of the
mining
is happening in kazakhstan and suddenly
you know they have
some kind of war or something over there
uh
you know you got to think about what uh
what effect that would have on bitcoin
that was all my only comment because uh
they again they buy uh they mine
approximately 18 almost 20
of the global uh bitcoin and that was a
surprise to me i i was not aware of that
uh why it ended up in kazakhstan i have
no idea could have just as well ended up
in afghanistan right
okay uh
fella says uh
i know this is this is a uh a uh
article that i put uh pulled out of the
international business times okay global
growth could slow shortly due to omicron
world bank so the world bank is saying
that this year
uh they have certain projections but
omicron might
cause some
uh problems with that i might you know
create some
uh
setbacks okay and so we may not grow as
much as we thought we would this year
and so this omnicron is also hanging in
the balance uh you know is is it gonna
develop into what it was like uh
2020 where
they shut down the the world and there
was a great loss of uh gdp everywhere
okay or is this just uh
you know
um
something that is just cosmetic is not
going to cause any change in the
projections of the world bank and again
the world bank is saying you know this
omnicron is is still a variable out
there that
uh might uh
change the values that they projected
okay essentially that's what they were
saying
okay and uh so here we have uh
uh
growth that were projected in 2019 this
was in july 2019 the chart on the top
and you can see that they projected
more or less
positive numbers
for 2020
but at the bottom the chart shows what
actually happened you can see that uh
we didn't do too well in 2020
and what continues now is all these
projections and i drew that red line
there okay
slanted red red line to show that the
trend for the next few years doesn't
look good
now hopefully if uh
that is if everything you know is more
or less in line with projections but if
you add to this now a war omnicron and
who knows what else a couple wars maybe
i don't know all bets are off maybe we
get another negative like in 2020.
you know so these are things you got to
think about
my assessment here it is i show it with
the map the only uh area in the world
that will be growing will be antarctica
the red zone there i think antarctica
has got a good chance to
grow its gdp and that's about it you
know i don't know about all the other
countries because a lot of countries are
not doing very well right now you know
if you look at country by country
man there's there's serious problems out
there and i don't think uh
the war
assuming and i'm almost sure war some
kind of skirmish is gonna happen uh
and all i can say is that's not gonna
help
any country okay it's not like one
country's got to take advantage of
because russia went down or the united
states went down a little bit and uh
some of the other countries say oh we're
going to take advantages go up no
remember we're all in a service economy
now service economy you're producing non
non nonsense you're you're producing
nothing okay but nonsense is probably a
better word
okay uh fella says here says we're
living in the oil age
collapse and he's talking about uh peak
oil okay
and i don't think piccola has anything
to do with anything
okay now uh
the russian pipelines for example that
go through ukraine by the way i forgot
to mention that you know the russian
pipeline goes through ukraine all the
way to the west to western nations and
the issue there is that you know the
russians can turn off
you know the ukrainian pipeline and turn
on the assuming right the uh nordstream
2 pipeline
and you know feed gas
through the uh
what is it the uh
through the sea
to uh germany and other regions and not
have to send it through through um
through um
what is it through ukraine
and so that's another control that the
russians have in this war and this
right now it's a it's a diplomatic war
but it might you know go beyond that but
anyways i don't think uh oil has
anything to do with it partly because
if we have problems we're gonna switch
over to other sources
uh of energy to use that term okay
there's wind energy there's nuclear you
know there's so so much
uh
other things that we have out there that
can uh
replace oil in the long run just you
know next maybe decade or so
that uh even if oil goes down and
there's few less and less oil out there
i think we just replace it remember
you know we replaced coal in the 19th
century with oil
okay but until then until the 19th
century was coal that ran just about
everything and in fact in some places
around the world they still do
this was uh just a little story about jd
rockefeller and he was one of the guys
who
really got rich
producing oil and replacing
coal
and what he did was uh create oil for
the kerosene
lamps okay and everybody had a kerosene
lamp or started having them and then uh
at some point in time he switched over
to cars
okay he
found that instead of producing kerosene
he could produce gasoline and
you know when the car industry boomed
well
you know he became rich
and it's interesting that in what is it
1911 they
they broke standard oil up like they did
with the baby bells uh the
the uh what is it the
um
uh telephone company
and they broke those up
and i think they and they did the same
thing with jd there okay so
uh but yeah you can replace a lot of uh
the i mean substitute if you can't do it
this way you do it that way you do maybe
you know renewable resources and so on i
i think uh oil is is not the last word
in other words right now a lot of the
cars are trying to manufacture them to
be electric cars and they can
you know power those maybe even with uh
dams rivers you know
i've been to the hoover dam uh in uh
what is it in nevada there
and
the border with arizona and it's a
monster operation they produce
electricity and so you know uh
you can produce electricity plug your
car there and you can run it so you
don't really need oil everywhere
and even though it would take some time
to phase that out sometimes it's a
question of money and investment and so
on so i don't know about that i don't
know if oil is very important at all
uh
for the world the energy world right
okay uh changing a little bit the
subject fall says
a hundred percent the mechanism of mass
extinction events may be dysgenics this
may have been what
uh informed us government policy
in the 1930s to pursue uh eugenics
okay a little bit of politics there
there you have the definition what
dysgenics and eugenics are one is the
decrease in prevalence of traits deemed
to be either socially desirable or well
adapted to their environment and the
other one is a selection the artificial
you know humans doing the selecting uh
something like hitler i guess try to do
in germany you know just get the blonde
blue eyes to live and all the rest to
die
and these are inheritable
characteristics in order to improve
future generations
okay
uh yeah
i don't think uh
you know mass extinction has anything to
do really with either one of these
things uh it's related to genetics only
in the sense that you know population
decline hurts the economy only in that
sense other than that you know i don't
think
genetics eugenics or this genius has
anything to do with a mass extinction
which is the one that's going to affect
us and so here are my uh
theories okay the mass extinction
uh what is it many species what is it
what is the definition
a mass extinction has to do with food
it's the collapse disappearance of an
entire food chain
one food chain disappears the other food
chain continues onwards as if nothing
okay background extension that's more
related to genetics and but it's really
got to do with the fact that a species
has grown old and yeah that's what i
argue here that a species can grow old
what is an old species does it have
anything to do or something to do or is
it necessarily to do
with how many times the earth goes
around the sun the answer is no okay
uh it has to do with when a
species when its population pyramid
overturns naturally
you can have a
you know a big accident where lots of uh
where
you know lots of individuals die
that's not an overturning of the
population pyramid i'm talking about a
natural overturning of the population
pyramid meaning that more and more
individuals are older beyond
reproductive age and fewer and fewer
individuals are in the reproductive age
that's what a
population pyramid overturned is
and happens naturally to all species
given enough time and those that succumb
to such
uh process
that's known as a background extinction
that species alone disappears nobody
knows why
i'm telling you why it's the background
it's got to do with the overturning of
the population pyramid which at the same
time because
of um
it's uh been inbreeding for
thousands
hundreds of thousands of years it has
also lost genetic diversity so you have
a double whammy you have a loss of
genetic diversity with the overturning
of the population pyramid that causes in
my theory that's what
causes a
uh background extinction mass extinction
disappearance of a food chain
okay
okay fella says
as regards the lack of human genetic
diversity and the unavoidable
consequence of inbreeding and the degree
of certainty you hold blah blah blah
blah blah
my god uh we gotta straighten this fella
out okay and the first step of the
scientific method is assumption okay an
assumption is not about certainty
you know so what you have to understand
is the scientific method and scientific
method the first step is known as a
hypothesis
which is a assumption you have to make
an assumption
every theory as it says there is built
on an assumption you must lay the
groundwork
the cornerstory the cornerstones of your
theory objects definitions and a
statement of the facts not the facts we
don't know the facts only mother nature
knows the facts we have to
set forth the uh
statement of a fact in other words your
version of what you think are the facts
okay and we take them you know we
concede your facts your version of the
facts just to understand your theory not
to believe it okay just to understand it
so you need to produce the objects the
definitions and the statement of the
facts okay that's known as a hypothesis
it's got nothing to do with certainty
with belief or opinion it has to do with
presenting
the assumptions so you build your theory
upon those assumptions your theory has
to follow from those assumptions okay
my theory rests not on the certainty but
on the assumption that inbreeding
eventually conduces to mentally
physically handicap offspring
okay i'm saying that as far as
um background extinctions go
and one of the underlying factors just
one of the underlying factors of a mass
extinction is
that inbreeding okay
is it because we become more vulnerable
to diseases to the environment we can't
change or adapt or whatever nonsense the
geneticists talk about no it's got to do
with something else it's got to do with
anyone who inbreeds is going to have
rotten children
that's the that's the theory here we
don't ask you to believe it
we're asking you to understand it and
that's what we use as an assumption for
uh any theory related to background
extinction okay
so that's
that's the idea you don't have to
believe it you just have to understand
it
and i work off of this hypothesis
because the amish inbreeding resulted in
handicapped children today we have
uh quite a bit few uh rare
very rare genetic uh problems in the
amish community and it's a good you know
you can say um
experiment by mother nature okay with
this uh group of people this tribe
called the amish okay they've inbred for
300 years and now they're having
problems okay so that's the point there
then the other one's calhoun's mice he
did it in two years i think he's the
first uh individual who created
homosexuality in the lab the mice became
and rats both you know they became
homosexual and autistic and he did that
in uh several generations it took about
two years to
something close to the year like 656
days something like that
and he did several of these experiments
uh about 30 years doing these
experiments
and the other one is the neanderthals
they lost genetic diversity so you can
check out look up do some research on
that you'll find that in the last 50 000
years
whatever what few
fossils we have from the neanderthals
even those show that there was a loss of
genetic diversity over time and i have a
couple of uh
papers that uh i
you know
filed away that i have uh for reference
where it shows this that i think there's
no doubt in anybody's mind that the
neanderthals lost genetic diversity over
time and at the end i don't know what
kind of neanderthals are coming out of
the females wounds okay so yeah that's
another reason that i uh like this
hypothesis this assumption what why i
work from this assumption
and the other one is the results that i
see in mankind today i see it all around
us
so you know you might say well just the
way you interpret yeah it is but
i i just have reasons for these
assumptions it's not that i pull them
out of you know my nose holes okay
uh yeah uh again you know it's uh
whatever assumptions you want to work
with those are the ones that i work with
and i work uh from them because of those
reasons okay so it's not
like i pulled them out of nowhere
okay um here's another issue phil says
do you have enough expertise to reliably
predict the outcomes of newly developed
genetic technology such as gmos crispr
mrna and platforms on the inbreeding
extinction theory
my god i don't know where these people
study but yeah
they're operating out of the old
uh
scientific method the one of the 19 no
what is the 17th century and so you know
these people are completely out of it
they have no idea what the scientific
method is
that's the problem they're working of
off of the one that mathematical physics
works off of
and that's not a scientific method at
all
it's the religious method so you can't
talk about if you ask these questions
shows that you have no idea what's over
what science is about okay and here it
is okay
in science we do not make predictions
okay predictions are the sole province
of mathematics irrationality in other
words mathematics is 150
irrational they only have irrational
explanations why because they end up
moving concepts around that's why it's
irrational and that's what you get for
following the scientific method created
in the 17th century so-called scientific
revolution
science is not equal to technology and
so to ask to relate science to
technology and say
uh what uh
technology can you predict
no you don't predict technologies okay
not in science that's done in the labs
it's got nothing to do with science at
all
in fact they do a lot of that by trial
and error
and in science we do not do r d you know
no research and development so we don't
so that question is completely off topic
in science
science what is it rational explanations
if it ain't rational it ain't science
that's how it is okay
what's irrational moving concepts and
undefined words primarily those two
and that essentially summarizes uh
mathematical physics mathematical
physics is in the business of moving
concepts around
they uh transfer energy and they warp
the time
and they shake the field you know it's a
vibrating field an excited field okay
so no that's that's not science but
that's that's what these people do and
when they say oh your computer wouldn't
work if it weren't for
quantum or gps wouldn't work if it
weren't for general relativity it just
shows again mental retardation that's
what it shows okay because science has
nothing to do with technology does the
fact that gps works
means that time is warped
that time is a physical object that is
warped like a banana does uh the fact
that your computer works does that me
prove
what quantum says that a particle can be
at two places at once
retain a particle to begin with because
it's a wave function collapse
so no uh technology does not prove
theories okay and those people who make
that mistake simply have not been you
know in touch with science they do
religion they think they're doing
science
okay
another fella along the same line says
about your opinion
opinion
uh that not only uh cannot we go to
another star or another galaxy but also
that we don't need to because the growth
rate of the human population is
decreasing and your prediction is that
we will soon reach that zero or worse
well his english is not good and i think
that's got something to do with uh
his understanding or lack of lack
thereof
and uh first of all we gotta
uh say this
so i'm gonna put it in there for a
couple times so he learns it well okay
listen carefully now please please try
to understand before one of us dies
now please please try to understand
before one of us dies
okay so please try to understand before
one of us dies
okay so here it is okay
theory is not equal to prediction okay
first of all theory is equal to
explanation okay prediction is a
description if you say
if you just say
that tomorrow there's going to be an
eclipse
you have you haven't explained anything
all you did was describe something
and if you want to explain well you can
only explain a consummated event means
you know you've got gotta explain
something that already happened
that means prediction uh is quite unlike
uh explanation okay prediction is only a
description without more as soon as you
explain why there's going to be an
eclipse tomorrow it's because you have
had some experience with uh eclipses
and now you're talking about the past
not about the future so it no longer is
a prediction
and again you're focusing on the wrong
aspect prediction is a bad habit of the
religion of mathematics that's all the
prediction is we don't do predictions in
science okay
the issue is not when okay time
the issue is the mechanism
okay so when we talk about the
extinction of man we're talking about
the mechanism not about when it is and
you can't use the word prediction
because it's got nothing to do with time
okay it's not an issue of time it's an
issue of when and i'll give you an
example uh let me put this over here for
a second here
um
you know i i make a prediction let me
make a good prediction
and here it is okay very precise okay
someday humans are gonna die
how's that for a prediction
he said well
yeah i mean
what does that mean i mean is that a
prediction
i mean if i say
that on the 1st of may of the year 2030
the last human is going to die
you could say that's a prediction but to
say that someday humans are going to die
you know i'm not sure you know there's a
difference in in those types of
predictions right
and then you have the supernatural
predictions known as uh you know
foretelling
and uh you know uh we have a lot of
those like in the bible
uh people making these like in
revelation they say oh this was gonna
happen to the world in the future
and they were all you know those where
god approaches the guy and
whispers something in his ears so he
says oh i've seen the light let me tell
you what i've seen
possibly was on drugs so we're not
talking about any of that we're saying
when we talk about extinction we're
saying
there's something humans can't do
anything about
that's got nothing to do with prediction
it's got to do with mechanism
okay we're talking about the mechanism
that causes a mass extinction like what
caused the mass extinction of the
dinosaurs and we go in and pick out a
mechanism say well this is what caused
the extinction of the dinosaurs now we
project that onto men and say can man
elude the same mechanism the same
process
and if man cannot elude it then we can
safely say that someday humans will
become extinct
and then the other issue is if the
theory itself shows that
the extinction is imminent then we can
say that very soon humans will become
extinct
it's got nothing to do with prediction
it's got to do with mechanisms and
unavoidability
and it takes you know
some people a long time to learn what
what uh this is about they keep focusing
on prediction of course they'll never
get it right
anyways uh the issue is not when the
issues mechanism and the issues what if
man encounters the the same predicament
okay
as for example the dinosaurs can man
overcome situation with intelligence
technology ability to foresee events and
react to them
and what we're saying is that uh you
know humans cannot avoid the same
mechanism that cost the lives of the
dinosaurs
and the plants they ate we cannot avoid
it
and so that's the issue and so if the
guy wants to insist on prediction well i
don't know i don't know what to tell
them okay
yeah again prediction is a bad word
okay uh
and there yeah uh here's here's another
situation okay let me put this up here
let me put this over here
ah
get a little screwed up here give me a
second
okay i'm back
okay so this is the situation file says
uh well this this is just a another
situation
i'm going to make a prediction i'm going
to make a prediction that
if you take one more step you're going
to fall
off the cliff okay you're going to fall
off the edge all the way to the bottom
of the
valley maybe kill yourself if it's far
enough
on the rocks
and you say uh
well but that's your opinion you
you're making a prediction you're uh
you're predicting your future you don't
know what's going to happen
well here we're talking about
inevitability we're talking about
unavoidability we're saying that if you
take that extra step
you know it's guaranteed you're going to
fall down
to the to the rocks below
and so
is the guy going to say well that's a
prediction
no it's not it's got nothing to do with
predictions got to do with
unavoidability the fact that this fellow
here
if he takes that extra step he cannot
avoid falling down
down the cliff
and so you know uh again these people
keep insisting on the wrong um
on the wrong issue talking about
prediction when we're talking about
unavoidability and inevitability okay
and here let me show you
uh
what this fellow said he said
in all this uh reasoning you have not
taken into account the inevitable
inevitable human desire for the
development of technology and the
challenges of death
uh first of all
you know we're not developing any more
technology
we're done with technology okay so
whatever comes now is cosmetic changes
on on stuff that we already have we make
the blue car red that's all that's all
we can do cosmetic changes right now
we've got no more inventions that at
least that will put people to work which
is the real value of of you know
inventions humanity wants to go into the
black sky uh erroneously called space
okay
it wants to walk
uh on the moon if once it wants to
wants to see the blue pearl with its own
eyes the question arises if humanity
went up and down on the moon six times
in four years in the years 69 to 72 of
the last century why don't we have an
astros aerospace company that takes us
back and forth to the lunar cities that
humanity would have built in
i guess the last 50 years
well for me it's it's unbelievable some
people still you know flat earthers
like this well surety uh
they believe we never went to the moon
and their argument is that we couldn't
have gone to the moon because we haven't
gone there in 50 years i mean we should
have built cities and had a whole you
know uh
land populated by now we never went
there again
and what these people don't understand
is that it costs a lot of money
to go to the moon
and for what to put to put a uh a
station there with 10 guys
doing what
you know we're gonna
feed them constantly so far away i mean
we do have the sky labs rolling around
and it's close by but going to the moon
is pretty far away it's more dangerous
more costly and for what the moon is a
bearing barren place they would have to
take enough oxygen to last a year at
least if they're going to stay that long
or maybe more
what would they do on the moon plant
potatoes
these people don't understand that
it was in a sense worthless to go to the
moon the only purpose was to develop
technology to take us to the moon which
could serve military purposes
that's why there was an effort behind
you know
developing rockets to go to the moon
other than that there was no purpose
just to go to the moon and say well just
a science project we made it there we
were able to touch the moon great and
bring some rocks back some sand
no there was no purpose to going to the
moon in the first place and there is no
purpose in going there now now they're
trying to get to mars why are they going
to mars
is there any purpose to go to mars are
we going to put a civilization on mars
are we going to evacuate the planet
earth and all go to mars
are we going to
plant potatoes and have commerce with
mars
there is no purpose whatsoever to go to
mars none whatsoever
assuming we ever get there because i
think extinction is gonna catch us with
our pants down you know surprises but
assuming you know we've got enough time
yeah we could conceivably get to the to
mars because i think that's within you
know the it's
it's feasible within the laws of
probability as far as i'm concerned but
go there and touch and come back and say
oh we made it to mars
that's a science project that that's not
that costs millions of dollars billions
of dollars and what does it achieve
again are we going to evacuate the earth
all go to mars assuming we do are we
going to have commerce with those people
with our great grandchildren do we need
to go to mars now we have enough space
here on earth we got more than enough
space right now we're not having
children here on earth
certainly we're not going to make it to
mars because there is no purpose we have
no reason to evacuate to planet earth we
have no reason we have no space problem
you know elbow room
no problem at all here living on earth
so uh you can go to mars you can go to
the moon if you want
we're staying here
rational people will stay here i mean if
you want to have a trip around the solar
system more power to you you know you
have a nice experience other than that
it's
it's
unproductive it doesn't do anything for
humanity
okay
okay let's move on to the subject matter
today which is the proton what the hell
is the proton
but before we can get to the fro proton
we have problems a little bit with
science okay some people have
problems with science we need to clarify
these points as a as an introduction
okay here it goes
okay so phil says isn't the reason
mathematical physics is the only game
currently precisely because no physical
uh mechanistic explanation can be
identified don't throw out the baby with
a bathwater
uh that's bill gates throwing uh
i
i need with with the bath water
yeah in fact it's the other way around
uh we we want to throw the baby out
together with the uh water with the wash
water okay we want
all of mathematical physics terminated
wiped out from the face of the earth
wiped out from
science it's not science
mathematical physics is religion
in fact
i don't even think it qualifies as
religion because it's not only
opinion but it's more than that it's
irrationality
and by irrationality i mean that they
don't even have objects with which they
do their physical interpretations
when you go into mathematical physics
they're moving concepts around
abstractions
that's what mathematical physics is
today
and so you know yeah we want to throw
the baby together with all the wash
water
so you said it right we want to get rid
of it all completely and so here's my
answer okay and puts it in the right
light
that's exactly what we do here math has
nothing at all to do with either science
or physics math is a language and
nothing but
math is neither the language of science
nor uh
nor of physics
math describes science explains okay
that's what science does so math has no
possibility an equation is just a
description
and the reason math can offer no
physical interpretation that is
mechanisms right for how the universe
works is that it has no power no ability
to explain
mechanisms require objects mathematics
you know mathematical physics has
neither objects nor valid definitions
there's not a single
worthwhile definitions in all
mathematics
okay so there are no definitions we
don't have definitions for the word
energy we don't have the definition for
the word mass we don't have a definition
for the word field they have no
definitions for any of these words
when they do have a definition when they
say oh yeah we do have a definition when
you look it up it's a bunch of numbers
and then they start moving these numbers
around they're saying these numbers are
moving through the air
okay so so again those definitions are
worthless in science you can't use those
you can't do that in science you can't
reify concepts
and math cannot tell you what exists out
there the invisible intangible stuff
that
mediates gravity uh magnetism
electricity math cannot tell you that
okay math is just a quantity
quantifiable
um
discipline that just these deals with
quantities and amounts that's it
and physics on the other hand is the
science of existence
so yeah we want to throw the baby
together with the wash water we want to
get rid of all of mathematical physics
in its entirety nothing survives of
mathematical physics okay that's the
position here okay
and
so that's our goal
whether we achieve it or not it's a
separate issue but that is our goal we
want to get rid of mathematical physics
completely uh mathematics that can
survive because that's out there that's
just doing equations but when those
people bring those equations into
physics and they say we can tell you
what exists out there and and how it
behaves
that's where we have a problem because
they do everything with particles which
ain't particles in the end they're just
a bunch of equations that they
go through the motions of treating as
particles okay that's one issue and then
the other ones all these concepts that
they have they're just concepts which
they reify forces time
space time four dimensional space time
unimaginable space time no we don't have
such monsters here in uh science so we
need to get rid of all the language
especially of mathematical physics that
they have invented in the last 400 years
we want to get rid of
baby completely okay we want to have a
new baby
kill that one
okay
uh fellas that continues it wasn't a
math equation responsible for the
discovery of the anti-matter particle
the positron oh my god
which resulted in the medical device
called the pet scan okay the pet scan uh
hasn't math produced actionable useful
knowledge that improves quality of life
poor valor
i don't know where he where he
learned
science obviously he learned very little
science must be a lawyer or maybe just
scrubs floors i don't know but he
certainly uh never learned any signs
whatsoever
okay so uh here's the answer to
his first issue that he raises there and
that is that you know anders
uh he didn't invented the positron he's
invented the supositron anderson
supposed he assumed that he was staring
at the trace made by a particle okay
because there you see the picture on the
left hand side uh next to the caricature
of anderson okay you see that scratch
mark there that curve okay
uh he's saying that was made by a
positron that's the proof he presented
and that's what he won the nobel prize
for her
i think a couple years later
anyways the issue is that
did that scratch mark how was it made
was it made in one shot
is that a groove or is that made out of
dots is it made out of different uh
points
so the picture on the right the upper
right you see what i'm showing there did
the particle bounce up and down making
those potholes
is that how we made that groove or or is
it a continuous
uh channel going from one place to the
other
which is because if it's a continuous
channel maybe uh anderson should look at
the end of that channel maybe he'll find
his particle
right his positron
because why did it stop there
where did it go
okay
and uh so he concluded that he had
discovered a particle predicted by dirac
called iraq right paul uh four years
earlier and known today as the positron
well we do it a little differently see
we don't do it with particles we're
saying that uh what we have is the
uh
threads and they're moving around at
great speeds because uh he put that
wafer in the chamber that was
magnetic and we're saying that this was
a magnetic process where the threads
made that groove there
and just hit it whacked it once with a
bunch of threads that went in that
region uh gazillions of times per second
okay
and so uh that's how that groove was
made so it's a little different than
what he suggests the process that we
recommend or
propose for how this happened we're
saying that this was not done uh like
mr anderson suggested
okay so
that's the first issue
but let's cover that other issue that
this
fellow raised
and here it is
ah
i can get it up here okay
science has nothing at all to do with
technology once again okay technology
developing of gadget developing gadgets
by trial and error
uh edison said it perfectly thomas
edison he said i have not
failed
i just found
10 000 ways that don't work
and that's a summary of uh of technology
and tesla accused edda who worked for
edison said you know if if edison had to
find a needle in the haystack what he
would do is go pull one straw at a time
until you found the needle
[Laughter]
and yeah so
you know
again that's technology in a nutshell
it's just trial and error it's got
nothing to do with science okay
and uh
what's the science technology rational
explanations okay science does not
invent or develop nuclear bombs
okay that's technology
in fact uh you have the iranians they
know a lot of math they know a lot of
stuff but they don't have a bomb
so one thing has nothing to do with the
other they have the
uh
you know the math necessary to know all
the relations and so on but they don't
have a bomb
okay science explains the subatomic
mechanisms that underlie a bomb's
workings
that's what science is not making the
bomb okay and despite the origins of the
word science syria okay science has
nothing at all to do with knowledge
okay so knowledge is equal to religion
why what is knowledge belief okay
uh justify true belief
that's what plato said and we still
haven't changed that in 10 000 years
and uh and yeah now this means that you
already know and that
means you believe in what you know
in your own theory
and that's got to do with religion it's
got nothing to do with explaining
objectively to someone else what your
mechanism is
okay so that's the difference
and yeah science is equal to explanation
okay so um
but uh let me add to that here give me a
second
uh here we propose a paradigm shift okay
we're saying that science has nothing to
do with observer prediction experiment
calculating knowing verifying proving
evidence r d research and development
and winning prizes especially that's
what they
excel in mathematics you know winning
prizes they give all these beauty
contest prizes out to
uh in in um
to to reward
uh
so-called knowledge
okay and so yeah science is rational
explanations and rational means that
you're not going to move up jason you're
not gonna move that you're not gonna
move concepts uh
you're gonna move objects that's what it
means
okay so yeah all these people who who
talk about technology and about you know
uh predictions and things like that
they're completely out of touch
science has nothing at all to do with
any of that
okay uh let's continue here let's start
with the
this leads us to the subject matter
today which is the proton and for that
you know the proton is regarded as a
positive particle
whatever positive is okay and one of the
issues today is you know what what does
positive mean um what does it mean in
physical terms that's that's the
question i'm asking okay
and for that you got to do a little bit
of history on what the word positive
what is positive okay and so here uh i
put a little outline very brief okay
brief history of
positive there
uh
one guy who mentioned that i think for
the first time there was another fellow
uh across the ocean in um
in
england i think his name william watkins
i think was his name but anyways uh this
fellow uh benjamin franklin i think he's
quite known okay 1747 he invents the
positive and negative uh words these two
words positive and negative he is really
more um
addition subtraction i think i've got it
here hold it
yeah the plus and minus that's what he
used but see in this uh paper that he
wrote uh really these were letters okay
that he uh corresponded with someone
across the ocean named by the name of
collinson okay and this is where he the
first words positively and negatively
arise okay and that's good old ben
franklin who came up with all this okay
and uh so he he comes up with this
notion of positive he was looking at
electricity he thought it was a fluid of
sorts okay
and he was talking about positive right
and then
[Music]
1919 skipping a lot of intermediaries
there
rutherford discovers the proton through
back scattering okay
and so this is where the notion together
with niels bohr they developed this
planetary atom where you have a nucleus
in the center and you have the little
bead going around okay
and according to niels bohr you know it
jumps back and forth between energy
levels or
as they were eventually going to be
called orbitals okay so we have the bat
scattering experiments okay
uh and what is interesting also you know
before i forget on the case of um
franklin okay he talked about positive
and negative and uh we already had a
little bit of a history on that uh with
peter peregrines and this guy was a guy
from the 13th century
and
he discovered
the words north and south pole okay so
the reason the magnets have north and
south pole which is like positive and
negative
uh again you know it's it's these are
just labels
uh and you can see it here in
peregrina's uh
letter to a friend he says that your
earnest request i will now make known to
you in an unpolished narrative the
undoubted
uh
though hidden virtue of the lodestone
lowstone being you know magnet
concerning which philosophers suffers up
to the present time give us no
information so he's going to give us
information that no philosopher gave us
until now okay we're we're eager to
understand it because it character it's
is because it is characteristic of good
things to be hidden in darkness until
they are brought to light by application
to public uh utility out of affection
for you i will write in a single style
about things
entirely unknown to the ordinary
individual so he's gonna reveal all
these secrets about the magnet let's see
what he found out says there are in the
heavens two points more important than
all others because on them as on pivots
the celestial fear sphere revolves yes
at least he believed in the in the round
earth right these points are called one
the arctic or north pole the other the
antarctic or south pole similarly you
must fully realize that in this stone
there are two points styled respectively
the north pole and the south pole if you
are very careful you can discover these
two points in a general way and then he
goes through the motion of uh telling us
how to discover which one's the north
pole and the south pole and again to
this day
all we know is what peregrine has
discovered in the 13th century north
pole south pole that's all they can talk
about they have no idea how a magnet
attracts another or what north
or south pole mean
what is what is
happening
in in the north and south pole
that makes it attractive or repulsive
okay
and uh the same way with franklin you
know
saying that it's uh positive and
negative what have we learned and we
haven't changed anything since these two
fellows since peregrinous and
and
franklin we still use north and south
pole and positive and negative we
haven't advanced a single inch since
their days okay
anyways anderson discovers the positron
as we saw a minute ago and uh it was
first predicted by mr direct okay so in
32 direct posits the positron okay and
four years later anderson discovers it
through his little experiment in which
all he shows is this little scratch mark
and that was what garnered him the uh
nobel prize
great okay
we still don't know uh what a positron
is
and uh it takes us to the subject matter
here
first of all uh we need to show that um
what a positive what
uh
proton what a proton is okay but let's
let's uh let me finish here uh gelman uh
mary gelman and uh
swag uh they formerly proposed quarks uh
those are what make up the proton okay
protons supposedly this ball something
like this i guess
but it's made out of three balls okay
and so i challenged anyone to put three
balls together and make up one ball
but that's essentially what we have
today
uh anyways uh 1968 uh four years later
they uh these three fellas supposedly
discovered the quarks that make up the
three balls that make up the ball known
as proton also the neutron and uh
eventually they came up with this notion
of proton is arbitrarily designated as a
positive again
and that's why we look at the history of
positive here positive no physical no no
physical notion of that no physical
interpretation for positive or for north
and south pole by the way
and no one has ever seen a proton
okay
we don't have any image of what a proton
looks like
too small we can't even see an atom let
alone a proton which is
gazillions of times smaller than an atom
and quantum mechanics assumption uh
proton is made of three quarks okay so
that's that's the starting point
for what a proton is this is what a
proton looks like okay here it is uh
give you a give it a second here
okay you have a proton the electron
running around it's a negative part of
the pro of the atom but if you take the
electron out what you're left with is
the proton okay
and this proton is allegedly positive
okay
it's just a ball that's how it's
represented we have no idea what it
looks like but they say well it must
look like a ball
and that's the way they always picture
it everybody imagines it as a ball
inside the center of the
nucleus of the atom
okay so this is it's no more uh mystery
than that okay
um here's a better image now this is uh
with the quarks inside it okay
one is the proton the other one's the
neutron again they're made of three
quarks
okay and so again we have these three
balls that make up one ball
they're moving around i guess they're
held together by gluons we don't know
what the mechanism is for that
okay so uh this is what we have today
this is what the if if you go to college
this is what they'll tell you this is
what they'll explain to you okay so it
doesn't get any better than that we have
no idea other than what you see there
let me get this thing out of here
okay and so um
takes it to this okay
the fatal conceptual problems with the
proton
okay and in qm especially with this
notion of positive okay
and first of all we have three positive
entities today
we mentioned two of them one is the
proton which is made of three quarks
okay
uh are the quarks positive negative well
you gotta find out how positive with
negative forms a positive proton you
know you got to figure that one out okay
and uh yeah you'll find the answers out
there
because it's all math these quarks have
only to do with math and i'll discuss
that sometime in the future okay
but then we have the positron which we
just discussed and
that's the opposite of the electron
and that is also a positive particle
okay but then we have the hole
you know when you have an electron it
moves in one direction
what leaves behind is a hole
and so you have the this
little uh
thing where you have the
you know the the little squares
and you move the square to to the
in your case to the
left
my case to the right okay and it leaves
a hole behind and so as the
these things move this way the hole
moves in the opposite direction that's
the notion of a hole
and uh that's used significantly you
know very important in uh semiconductors
and so we have three positive
particles
okay
and three notions of it and that's going
to be a little bit of problem in fact
it's going to be fatal as you'll see in
a second okay here's the lhc
accelerating protons positrons or holes
you have the lhc and they say they they
have this long beam line
under vacuum they say they're
accelerating protons they ionize the
the proton let's assume hydrogen i'm not
sure exactly which ones they accelerate
but that's just for the sake of argument
you take the electron out of the pro of
the atom you leave the hydrogen atom you
leave the proton now you're going to
accelerate protons you're going to
collide protons against each other
are we accelerating protons are we
accelerating holes maybe because the
electrons going the other way right
so it's going in the positive direction
is it the proton that's moving or is it
the hole
along the the series of atom that is
moving forward or maybe they're
positrons
these positive particles you know the
opposite the anti-matter of electron
maybe those are the ones that are moving
how do we know
we can't see any of them
okay
are protons accelerate or vibrating in
situ
okay
well the energy or signal travels
remember we heard the other day from uh
this fellow derrick mulder and he said
and lots of other people out there
i pick on him but there's they all say
the same thing
the electrons are not really
accelerating in electricity they're
moving very little locally
especially when you have alternate
current meaning they move back and forth
back and forth back and forth while
vibrating they also
coil around
okay we talked about that last time so
we have coiling moving back and forth
locally
so it's moving what's moving at the
speed of light from one end of your
circuit to the other
well they're saying it's the energy
it's the signal
two concepts that's what's moving
the thing
the electron some going anywhere
is that the case also for the protons is
the proton going nowhere is it just
moving locally
so when they say they accelerate protons
at the lhc along the beam line and that
they collide
these protons which they've accelerated
all around the beam line right
are they accelerating protons or are the
protons just moving locally
and what's
moving is the energy and they're
colliding energies
okay keep that in mind
and again is the lhc smashing smashing
energies or colliding signals what are
they doing what are these people doing
do they know can they see what they're
doing or is this just math
which they've converted into physics
okay and so here's a good old derrick
muller i showed him
some time back okay
and he's he had a little show
saying the big misconception about
electricity
and what he was suggesting is
essentially you know at the end of the
show was that the electrons are not
really moving
anywhere they're moving locally and so
let me show you that so that you know
what i'm talking about first of all
here's a circuit okay and you can see
the electrons aren't moving all the way
to the other side this is alternate
current okay and what they're saying is
it's moving locally very
few millimeters per second
and second which is not there shown
there but you know they coil around
locally that's another issue you got to
think about
but they're not moving so it is moving
you know so again if electrons are not
moving are protons moving
along the beam line or is you know is
the electricity going in one direction
they say well the protons are going in
the other direction
are the protons really moving are they
moving locally okay
and here you have another uh image of
this okay uh this is what
derek muller said he said that these
electrons are moving
locally okay
and
so they're not moving very
far and what's moving really is the
energy he says or the signal whichever
you want and if the electrons are moving
back and forth locally
you know just a few millimeters then uh
are the protons moving
or you know is the whole uh is every
proton in in a material in the wire
moving from one end of the wire to the
other
and when they're accelerating protons
are they accelerating actually
moving the protons from one end of the
you know the circle to the other
let me show you here
okay
here's a uh
ions flowing along a beam line this is
the type of work that i did we used ion
accelerators
and this is what allegedly this is what
we thought we did okay we've created a
species uh
in our case we did either boron or
phosphorus typically
and we ionized it in other words we in
the case of
these atoms you either put an atom uh an
electron in or you remove an electron
okay and the issue is to make it
negative or positive by doing so you
accelerate it along the beam line with
magnets which are on the outside of
those blue lines there
and what happens is all the species is
coerced is forced to move along the beam
line okay
and so what this is the process of
creation and acceleration of ions
is this what we did
did we accelerate ions
like here you'll see it on the lac okay
is this what we did did we accelerate
all these
ions from one end to the other
or did they stay in place
and something else reached the other end
and you know these people would say that
energy but is that what we what they
collide they collide energies what does
that mean how do you
how do you collide two concepts that's
the issue okay
okay so um
here are the possibilities
okay
uh with holes you know you've got um
a situation i mentioned a minute ago
with the 16 square puzzle
if the electron moves from one atom to
the other you can see in its negative
you see the positive holes are moving in
the opposite direction
and this is another so-called positive
particle if you can call the absence of
an electron a particle okay but this is
what they use as current in
semiconductors this is how they explain
it this is their physical interpretation
so we have uh again we have all these
three
um
particles you could say or
that are positive
you have the proton the positron and the
holes
and we can't see any of them
and so they say they accelerate them
which one do they accelerate and then
they say that they don't really
accelerate what accelerates is the
energy the protons the positrons or
whatever they just spin in place
that's the situation today for that's
the physical interpretation okay so keep
all this in mind these are questions you
should ask yourself or you should ask a
quantum mechanic
to explain in detail to you what is
accelerating how do they know did they
see it did they film it or is this the
calculation is it an assumption of the
equipment see the equipment is built
already to
consider any blip in the system as a
particle
they don't know what that blip is
okay but they see a hump on
on a camera and they say a particle
and so a hump a double hump
on a camo uh you know it's not really a
uh a particle
so are they looking at particle well
they say it's a wave and a wave is not a
particle either and they can't be
reconciled a wave is extended a particle
is localized and so you got all these
problems that have not been resolved in
quantum mechanics okay and so here you
have you know again this is what the
whole version is where you know you move
the little square and what you leave
behind is a hole and this is their
mechanism for semiconductors for holes
so they have the current of
electricity which is the electrons and
then they have the whole current which
is supposedly the
positive current okay
so keep all this in mind you know what
are we talking about with all these
positive so-called particles
okay so here you have the the situation
okay on a beam line what can you be
accelerating well here's particles this
is the notion that they have that
they're accelerating protons okay
we don't know if that's what they're
accelerating but this is their notion
that what's going from one end of the
beam line to the other end are a bunch
of protons great
okay uh here's the rope version of that
same thing uh we're saying that what's
actually
happening is that the atoms are sliding
along the ropes okay
this is one of the versions probably the
most uh likely
there's another possibility i want you
to think about this okay and it's like
this you've seen a drill
okay
you
press the button and the drill bit
twirls in place
the drill bit goes nowhere okay
everything drills in place
rotates in place but you make a hole in
the wall
okay so it has an effect at the tip
of the uh
drill bit
okay
and so now let's look at the beam line
with that notion with this notion what
if we had all these drill bits they're
twirling in place
nothing is moving from left to right all
you have is
in-situ
rotation
and you have an effect
at the end of the beam line
okay so this is another possibility if
all the atoms are merged together what
you have is electricity
in one direction and you have the
so-called positive electricity the holes
the pro protons maybe even the positrons
going in the other direction in other
words there are no particles what you
have is atoms which are merged together
in long lines which we call serpentines
these serpentines um twirled in place
and it causes an effect at the end of
that certainty that's what we're saying
is probably happening also you know
inside the beam line when you either
when they say they accelerate protons we
think that this is another possibility
so there's two possibilities one is the
sliding of atoms along the rows which is
very possible it's probably the most
likely scenario but this is another
scenario you should consider the fact
that maybe nothing is sliding maybe
everything just twirls in place and you
have a drill effect at the end okay
so that's for you to ponder we don't
shove it down your throat we ask you to
understand it ponder it chew it whatever
okay and reach your own conclusions
and so once again these are the things
you have to consider when analyzing
quantum mechanics version uh
physical interpretations uh the fatal
concepts and that's that they have three
particles positive particles the proton
the positron and the whole we don't know
which one they're accelerating we don't
know if they are accelerating
and
if they're not accelerating what's
accelerating is energy is mr um derek
muller and others say
are we smashing energy bits energy uh
concepts is that what we're smashing
at the lac and the slack and the
fermilab all these
accelerators
food for thought
okay so let's move on here to the
questions we had since last time
let me get this in here
and here we go okay
so vacuum is the absence of mass number
of objects in a volume
yeah and i guess an object is the
absence of vacuum is that how we're
going to define an object what is an
object it's the absence of vacuum
yeah you can't define things in the
negative
negative definition is an antonym
meaning it's a synonym
in other words it's got to do you can't
use synonyms and antonyms to define
words you can't say a dog is not a horse
that's not a definition
okay
and so
again keep in mind you can't use
negatives
or synonyms you can't use antonyms or
synonyms to define words scientifically
in ordinary speech you can do anything
you want and in mathematics obviously
you can also
now the file says if these supposed
magic
ropes of the one phantom thread are in
tension torque why would everything slam
together into one ball of thread
and i'm wondering what does
electromagnetic ropes under tension have
to do with atoms slamming into one ball
of thread
again you know
these people really make me laugh
because they can't even come up with
rational questions
yeah one thing has nothing to do with
another the at least you would think
that he would go out of his way to say
look because this is the situation this
is what i'm thinking but
what he said makes no sense it's like
saying
uh if i drive my car on thursday why are
apples red
i don't know
talk to your
shrink
okay
paul says it fields and energy energy
types haven't been defined why is it i
can look them up in dictionaries
encyclopedias search engines agreed on
by engineering
science physics and copy paste them
uh yeah he realized i guess on ancient
dictionaries of some kind sorts
uh
what can we say well here's the answer
in science we don't agree first of all
okay in science we don't agree to
disagree in science we justify and
defend our definitions so we don't care
how many people raise their hands on
planet earth to come up with these
definitions that's not going to cut it
it's not a question of democracy it's
not a question of how many it's a
question of can you defend your
definition does your definition make
sense can you use it consistently those
are objective criteria okay and again
agree disagree that that's just religion
in ordinary dictionaries written by
librarians and english majors who have
no stake in physics they introduce
definitions of ordinary speech
okay so they just use words which are
not scientific you can't go to the
ordinary dictionary and expect to get a
scientific definition out of there okay
and when you go to the
uh scientific definition in your
dictionary and you find a definition of
ordinary speech again it doesn't mean
that because it's in a science so-called
scientific dictionary that the guy broke
his head figuring that definition out he
just copied from the ordinary dictionary
and put it in the so-called scientific
dictionary that's it we don't have any
definitions for field for energy for
mass in so-called scientific
dictionaries so you know you got to
think about that
and yeah mathematicians don't care about
definitions that's the bottom line they
think all that is just word solid you
know word wizardry and so they don't
they don't get into that because they
say well you're just doing semantics
okay so they don't do semantics they
just do nonsense and they turn concepts
into objects they reify all their
concepts
uh no dictionary on earth has rational
definitions for even the most common
concepts of mathematical physics and
here you have a couple of examples are
these objects or are they concepts can
these words be used to carry out action
verbs can you use energy to push a wall
can you use mass to hit a baseball out
of the ballpark
can you
warp time can you vibrate a field what
do you do you shake it up and down i
mean you know none of these words
represent objects and so that's the big
problem that they reified all these
concepts and they treat them as if they
were objects
okay um
foul says
cause of gravity is unknown
uh-huh
but aren't the concepts of gravity's
effects
useful to navigate the unknown physics
of reality
well yeah we all know
dude
we all know why the child is crying the
toddler baby is crying because
he dropped his spoon on the floor and he
can't eat his porridge
you know that why that's that's
philosophy okay we know the reason
why he's crying okay
the cause
of why the spoon fell to the floor now
that's a different matter that's the one
where we try to get to
you know try to understand in physics
and so the question is why did that
spoon fall to the floor not to the sky
to the ceiling
okay and so he says the cause of gravity
is unknown
well maybe he doesn't know
but you know it's it's more fundamental
than that it's uh that knowledge is not
a part of science
okay so you can't use the word no in
science
no belongs to religion
in science we don't know or care to know
knowledge is personal conviction belief
that's what knowledge means
it's religion it means that you
have uh
when you say that you know something
it's because you believe it
no one else in the world knows like you
do okay
they have a different knowledge
and science is not about knowledge it's
about rational explanations you have to
explain something rationally
rational you have to
use objects
and not reify concepts and you have to
have good definitions definitions that
you can use consistently
okay that's what rational is
and the rope hypothesis has rational
explanation for gravity and there you
see it at the bottom every atom
from the moon that makes up the moon is
uh bound to every atom that uh makes up
the earth so the reason the moon doesn't
fly out of the solar system in other
words gravity right
is that all atoms are interconnected and
that's the same with a baby there the
reason the
spoon fell to the floor is every atom
that makes up the spoon is connected
to physically connected to every atom on
earth see how easy it was so it's no
magic okay
there is no magical action at a distance
essentially all atoms are physically
interconnected once we make that
invisible intangible mediator visible
gravity is a piece of cake
okay so yeah we do know
to use your term
okay uh what causes gravity
uh
we explain it so that you understand it
and once you understand it it's really
kid's stuff you say oh that's
kindergarten stuff if all atoms are
interconnected obviously the spoon has
more chance of falling towards the
center of the earth where
most of the matter on this planet is
accumulated at then to the sky where
everything is you know first of all
gases and then all you have is space all
the way up to the moon the nearest
object so that's too far away and so the
spoon will fall to the center of the
earth because all atoms are physically
interconnected now it's a piece of cake
because now you see now you understand
you visualize
gravity so the cause of gravity we can
explain it
whether you believe it or not that's
your personal business we don't care
that's got nothing to do with science
that's got to do with religion we
explain so that you understand the
mechanism
okay that's that's how science works
that's how physics works not how
mathematics works for sure
okay another file says a theory involves
repeatable experiments with consistent
observations that have been
peer-reviewed
reviewed by whom
by the dalai lama by the pope who peer
reviews i mean who's got the authority
to peer review and nobody knows anything
about gravity for example okay
and so uh here is uh my answer okay uh
this guy has a theory okay and so the
question is um
he did the experiment okay
and he observed
and he had it peer reviewed and it's
approved and his theory is that angels
move the earth around the sun
okay so uh
just because it's a repeatable
experiment meaning the earth can be seen
going around the uh sun maybe by a
satellite for example that's got a
camera okay so we we can film it maybe
right over time
uh maybe
so we can observe it and
you know repeatable in the sense that we
can wait two three years and always the
earth will go around in the same circle
okay
and uh
and so
we we observed it we did a repeatable
experiment so what's the cause is it
angels moving the earth around the sun
is that what you observed
so again you know uh none of this
repeatable uh experiment and observable
and
peer-reviewed has anything to do with
science that has to do with belief okay
and belief is not science belief is
religion
okay
okay phil says
if weight is the same as mass
where where
where are where are rate of fall
terminal velocity and gravitational
constant derived from
well the
fella is a little bit disoriented okay
it confuses the notion of weight and
mass of physics
with those of mathematics that's his
problem okay mathematics is not science
and so it is in uh in mathematics
weight and mass uh weight is equal to
mass they're the same okay because mass
is weighed to obtain mass
okay so you weigh the mass and you say
that's the mass and what is the mass is
the weight it's in kilograms what is
kilograms weight
we're done okay
uh in physics mass uh is equal to number
of atoms
okay that's the notion that we have in
physics of what mass is so we just say
quantity of atoms you want to say mass
that's fine no problem weight on the
other hand is number of independent rows
converging on an object at a given uh
this location from uh from another given
distance okay
and here we have a picture of that i
showed this in the past here it goes
there you have mathematical physics mass
is equal to weight why because uh they
say weight is a force
which it ain't
its attention okay because uh there is
nothing moving during weight you have
weight only for a given location in in
space to use that term okay
uh we determine mass in other words in
mathematical physics right um
and weight both of them threw away
that's how we determine that no one
counts atoms
okay
and the problem here is that in the
weight equation
that's uh
some call it newton's gravitational
equation okay that's fine uh
weight is a force and they say force is
equal to that that you see there the
gravitational constant g mass 1 times
mass 2 divided by distance squared where
that distance squared is separation
between the two masses the two objects
the reason they put a value there is
they pace from one object to the other
and they say with so many meters because
they unroll their
measuring tape from one object to the
other that's why they put that distance
squared in terms of meters
what it is in physics is you have two
objects mass one and mass two they're
just two objects and they're separated
by a given distance if you change the
distance by a single millimeter a
micrometer an angstrom
you no longer have the same weight
so that distance is a separation in
physics between two masses that's what
weight is therefore it's not a force
it's a tension
okay and tension is not a force because
no one wins the tug of war between the
earth and the moon at a given time a
given cross-section of time okay
and so there you have it you see why um
why
weight in
physics is the number of independent
ropes converging on an object there you
see the astronaut of different distances
different locations from the earth and
the closer he gets the
ropes
open up they separate they're no longer
on the same axis
and so now they
they act independently there's tension
along each one of those ropes at any
location and so all you have to do is
count the number of ropes and you got
weight
okay so that's how simple it is
so yeah uh it's in mathematics where uh
weight is equal to
mass not in science okay
they they say it's the same because you
know they weigh it
and they never count atoms they define
mass as quantity of matter but they
never use that they because they never
specify their result
in terms of number of atoms they don't
say this object has one trillion atoms
you'll never hear them say that they say
it weighs one kilogram that's how they
state
their mass
but what have they stated they stated
the weight
of the thing in kilograms and then they
say yeah but see if it's on the moon it
has a different weight
yeah and it has a different mass because
you're going to weigh it over there to
determine the mass and it has a
different mass as well over there
they say yeah but the number of atoms
has not changed
how do you know you haven't counted the
number of atoms before you left
you never counted the number of atoms
before you left or when you arrived you
never counted the atom you always
weighed
you put it on the scale
and when the scale stopped
when it there was no more motion that's
the value of weight in other words there
is no force
it's tension because there is no motion
weight is not a force because there is
no motion
during weight
as soon as it moves
all bets are off you got a different
weight
so
it's very hard for all the
mathematicians who learned this for by
memory by road for 400 years to
understand that today okay no
weight
is not a force
it's using the
gravity the gravitational universal
gravitational equation which is not a
force
because the distance in that equation is
not the distance traveled of mathematics
it's the distance of physics separation
between two objects how do you tell that
to a mathematician
he doesn't do qualitative stuff he just
does quantitative stuff says oh
uh the numbers they match
yeah but you're matching lions against
tigers you know
what are you doing you don't even know
what you're doing
okay
here we have another question another
comment phil says if illustrations of
these ropes in magnetism are correct why
doesn't the geometry match what we
observe with magnetic viewer film
ferrocells uh 3d field viewers etc
well maybe it's because you don't
understand the difference between a
thread and a rope we never said the rope
does anything it's the thread that works
in
in magnetism so
apparently you're not aware of the
difference between a thread and a rope
in fact swinging threads do match the
pattern of magnetic fields what evidence
do you have that they don't
okay and uh here we show the pattern
okay
just to
put our money where our mouth is okay
there it is okay you see the patterns on
two wires conducting
electricity in the same direction
on the left and you see two wires
parallel wires conducting electricity in
opposite direction on the right okay the
ones on the left they both swing the
threads clock counterclockwise and here
you have the two little guys axel and
rod that i always use and uh well axel's
rope the blue guy's rope comes up
rod's rope comes down and that's when
they uh interact and that's what's
happening in the center of those two
wires between them
and in the case of repulsion we turn
axel around now uh he he's uh stringing
his ropes clockwise
and
i like to say that the pattern reflects
uh or pretty much
resembles right
a um
one of those old uh
drying machines washing machines where
they used to dry the clothes through two
rollers
and so that's that's the image i have of
that and so what you have is essentially
you're squeezing the water out of shirt
and what you have is the clockwise and
counterclockwise rotation of the threads
okay again we're talking about threads
not ropes very big difference there okay
so that's the first thing this fall
needs to understand and so yeah when you
have that situation you can explain now
the patterns that he was talking about
so it's very simple the patterns do
match so i don't know what he's talking
about maybe he
he hasn't even looked at this okay and
here we have another uh thing that he
would have to explain you know here you
have magnet underwater and you can see
that the iron filings
are pulled one by one essentially you
know by um
by by the magnetic field whatever
magnetic field is so there's something
moving inside what we call a magnetic
field we're saying it's those threads
which are swinging around at great
speeds and pulling
those mag those uh iron filings towards
the magnet that's what's happening so we
don't see the
the threads they're swinging around
great speeds and we at least have a
mechanism for why those iron families
are moving towards the magnet what does
he propose
i mean what physical object is moving
those iron filings that's what he's got
to explain anybody has to explain who
wants to tackle this problem
okay so yeah we do have a an explanation
and it's got to do with the threads the
threads are swinging around and they do
resemble the patterns that we see in
magnets so
where does he get this notion that they
don't
he's got to provide some
evidence of some kind or talk a little
more describe in more detail his
question
you know right now he's got no case
okay final issue here there are only
three ways of acquiring factual
knowledge by the evidence
of the senses by proof and by testimony
my dear god
well in science we have no facts so
acquiring factual knowledge whatever
that is
there's no evidence no proof no
testimony and no knowledge for sure
right if you don't understand this you
have no senses meaning
common senses
we'll see you next time and i'll see you
on wednesday